the oxford covid vaccine
is still being tested but such is the
urgency that the manufacturers are
already
priming their sterile production line
vockhart in wrexham could start filling
vials as soon as november
20 million doses could be produced every
month
then quarantined until the vaccine is
approved by safety authorities
if it's not the entire stock will have
to be destroyed
this is a risk that one has to take
considering
the enormity of this pandemic
if the vaccine does not get approved
then obviously it will not be used
but this is i think an unprecedented
step taken by the government of uk
in the interest of the uk public
the pharmaceutical industry has never
made so much vaccine
so quickly and the bottleneck will
almost certainly be what's called the
fill and finish don't underestimate the
challenge
of what's going on in here you've got
several different supply chains
all coming together there's not just the
vaccine but the glass
vials the rubber stoppers and the paper
labels
if there's a hiccup on any one of those
that will delay the
final product the global pharmaceutical
industry has the capacity to make
2 billion doses in 2021 but almost
all the vaccines in late stage clinical
trials need
two doses to work so even by the end of
the year
barely one in ten of the world's
population could be protected
we have to be clear that in the first
instance not everybody will have access
to the vaccine
we do not have the manufacturing
capacity
to make the vaccine available to
absolutely everyone
especially not the vaccines that are
currently in advanced clinical trials
vaccines are in final stage clinical
trials around the world
putting pressure on the manufacturers of
vials which have to be made with a
special glass
the german company shot has deals with a
dozen pharmaceutical companies
but is keeping back some production
capacity just in case the game-changing
vaccine comes from elsewhere
how much of a challenge will it be to
meet the demand of a kovid 19 vaccine i
can
simply say we are we are prepared we
have
set up additional capacity for roughly 2
billion doses
we have had many discussions with
pharmaceutical companies what is their
need and what do we need to
prepare in addition from start to finish
every part of the global vaccine
production line is primed
but is about to face its toughest ever
test
thomas more sky news